we're ready cool ready I'm ready are you
ready so no hey you we hope you're
enjoying your holiday season like you
we're also taking a few days off from
saying things like hey guys hey guys hi
guys hey fam this Sunday at aj+ and
doing things like live at five Sena can
you be on I bear alert baby pains are
you quiet aj+ relax it oh my god just
watch the video I would advise that
everyone maintain a strict level of
professionalism going forward thank you
very much to show you just how we at ag+
in-depth operate get to know how I'm
Sunnah I'm Anna I'm Omar I'm stream and
me a Mayan get the news to you don't
worry we're coming back next Sunday with
the intriguing in-depth and creative
stories you're used to seeing from us in
the meantime learn what we've been doing
how we make it all come together and
what's next in 2018 what you're used to
seeing looks a lot like this one of us
on camera preparing to dive deeply into
a topic let me show you the dozens of
pins you're seeing right now are all
locations where the United States has
had some sort of presence but have you
ever wondered how we get from
information gathering to something like
this now it's easy to think of the
Philippines as all the way over there
and the United States right over here
each one of our videos starts off as a
pitch we then have producers write and
research part of that process is making
a lot of phone calls and interviewing
experts and the people affected and
sometimes the process can involve some
unexpected turns
this is so people yes that really
happened it was part of our preparation
for this Orientalism piece which ended
up looking like this he uses red bottoms
these is bloody shoes yeah I put about
once we have all our background
information have gathered all our
interviews and have done all of the
dances we start writing and perfecting
drafts the Americans wasted no time in
building Puerto Rico in their image from
the public education system to making
English an official language to
replacing the peso to even bring in the
US Postal Service after we script it we
film interviews with our experts as well
as the presenters on-camera segments
like this one then we send it to an
editor who crafts a basic version when
the editor is done the story goes to our
animation team where we work with
designers to visualize our stories our
animators will sometimes spend a whole
week creating designs and animations and
putting the finishing touches on our
stories lastly there's the final
approval process before it comes back to
you looking something like this but what
they might not think about is the money
behind it well first you need to know we
literally create the studio every time
we have to shoot in-house it began as
this before transforming into the homey
space we're sharing right now and then
there's the question of story selection
how do we choose what tales to tell this
Sunday we're gonna talk to you about why
people left China in the first place and
how they ended up here in the US he's
just one tool Big Oil is using to
influence the public school system we
get our story inspiration from what's
going on in the current news cycle
questions that arise in our daily lives
and sometimes we get our story ideas
from you that's right we see you in the
comments section and we're actually
paying attention let me answer a few of
your questions I greet you with hey fam
because we're community Senate says
Philippines that way because she's kind
Philippines Philippines Philippines
Philippines I don't I actually don't
hear it so you should keep talking to us
keeps telling us what you would like us
to explain 2017 was the year we covered
stories like why does it matter if it
leat schools have many more wealthy
students and they do low-income ones
since then winning citizenship rights
for people of color has been an uphill
struggle mas gang rapes killings
including of babies and young children
despite the crackdown on Sen su Chi with
her charismatic speeches her father's
name became the voice of the opposition
we do things with levity but we can also
be quirky at least twice we found a way
to add singing and dancing into our
stories a whole new world on TV we've
also never shied away from talking about
identity and race it's one of the most
persistent Asian American stereotypes
and comes with some really harmful
consequences from the time that they
were founded HBCUs are dedicated to
helping these students succeed and in
2018 we'll be doing some of the story
ideas you gave us in 2017 so please be
on the lookout thank you so much for
watching and come back next Sunday when
we have another awesome video don't
forget to subscribe like share is this
where I say all that we should leave it
all there just like that